public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
jean-marie le guen le secrétaire d'état
aux relations avec le parlement est
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec les
échos radio classique et l' agence
france-presse
trois grandes questions au programme
d'abord est ce la fin des réformes
jusqu'en 2017 pascal programme des échos
vous poserai la question
ensuite françois hollande va t'il
s'incliner devant emmanuel macron qui
réunit ses supporters ce soir à
strasbourg et qui a le vent en poupe
aussi long d'après les sondages marquent
près de la fp vous interrogera sur la
présidentielle est également sur la
primaire donc enfin troisième question
dire qu'avec la droite ce serait pire
est ce suffisant mickey la messe de
public sénat nous rejoindra enfin pour
aborder ce thème donc et votre argument
que l'on entend à gauche sont tous les
cas depuis quelques temps maintenant
mais d'abord jean marie le guen une
question d'actualité
la mobilisation pour sauver alstom à
belfort l'état commande donc des tgv
pour les utiliser comme intercités
c'est-à-dire à petite vitesse et saab
surdes non pas à petite vitesse à
vitesse normale à deux vitesses mais non
c'était pas absurde ce qui est absurde
c'est que nous avons une industrie
nationale des chemins de fer qui est
soumise aujourd'hui à des aléas de
circonstance et dire que nous savons
qu'à partir de 2020 il y aura un
programme de charge très important très
important et il faut disent ils à
conserver des compétences de l'activité
et donc c'est un sursis qui a été
décidée aujourd'hui avec le cépage blanc
du frioul pas si c'est un plan
industriel global
vous avez peut-être pris déjà en plus
ces trains corail mais qui sont bordeaux
nice en l'occurrence c'est à dire c'est
un voyage important et qui est fait dans
des conditions aujourd'hui qui sont tout
à fait lamentable donc je pense qu'il ya
une amélioration de la qualité et il ya
en même temps la mise sous tension de
notre filière industrielle
donc je pense que c'est un compromis
intelligent entre la capacité le
maintien d'une capacité industrielle
l'amélioration du service à la clientèle
et la résolution d'un problème
économique et social compromis
intelligent qui a un coût à plus d'un
demi milliard même très près d'un
milliard sur certaines estimations
donc pour sauver 400 emplois qui n'était
pas menacé jean marie le guen simplement
qu'ils risquaient d'être déplacé en
alsace je comprends la difficulté pour
les gens sur place mais est ce
raisonnable mais bien évidemment
présenté comme ça ça ne serait pas mais
ce n'est pas la réalité ce qui est la
réalité c'est le maintien et la
reconfiguration puisque vous parlez
dans le détail de ce qui peut se passer
alstom belfort c'est une reconfiguration
complète de lusine de belfort c'est le
maintien de compétences qui aurait fait
défaut en 2020 et qu'ils auraient à à ce
moment-là a mené à ce que et bien on
soit obligé d'importer en quelque sorte
d'être un de ses tweets le juge a
malheureusement la sncf on l'a vu c'est
d'ailleurs de cette affaire les cébettes
sncf dans une filiale dans une filiale
commune
soyons précis un jeu c'est pas la sncf
ces îles la filiale commune de la sncf
et de la deutsche bahn c'est à dire ça
ne serait pas le monde pour un train
particulier on faire l'appel d'offres
que malheureusement alstom n'a pas
remporté ce qui pose d'ailleurs le
problème aussi delà du fait que cette
entreprise doit aussi se remettre en
question je viens au moment où je vous
parle je vous dis il s'agit pas de
suppléer les défauts d'une entreprise de
sa compétitivité de son adaptation au
marché
par exemple si une entreprise qui a
beaucoup travaillé sur la gamme tgv mais
qui a assez peu travaillé sur les gammes
intermédiaires
donc il y à une remise en cause cette
entreprise ses dirigeants doivent aussi
ne pas toujours attendre effectivement
que l'état soit si j'ose dire la prise
très cyan tout à fait mais je le premier
ministre l'a fait nous pensons pas que
l'état
puis en permanence se tenir en mai
justement aujourd'hui il ya un effort
des pouvoirs publics nous demandons à
l'entreprise de s'adapter à cet effort
est-ce que vous n'aurez donnait pas le
beau rôle puisqu'il l'a encore le
premier ministre a répété que c'était
une action de l'état stratège mais
beaucoup d'observateurs y compris dans
votre camp enfin benoît hamon dit plutôt
que c'est un étape politique qui essaye
de sauver les meubles avant la
présidentielle sujet benoît hamon sur ce
sujet comme sur d'autres auraient
peut-être pu réfléchir un petit peu à ce
qu'il disait et a été de tirer contre
son propre camp ça devient une manie
mais au-delà de l'aspect politique des
choses lorsque moi j'ai entendu pendant
dix ans que le rafale
c'était quelque chose qui était qui
n'existait que par les commandes de
l'état d'accord pendant 10 ans on a
entendu que ça une certaine presse des
commentateurs du gel rafale aurait pas
le vendre mais pourquoi l'état dépense
était là aujourd'hui on remplace
domaines stratégiques de l'armée et la
défense est ce que le ferroviaire
ça descend l'agencé bande agissant de la
fir français de l'industrie ce que ce
n'est pas stratégique
nous avons fait régulièrement ce
gouvernement a fait ses clips de leurs
matières industrielles
nous avons sauvé stx nous avons sauvé
psa nous avons encouragé des entreprises
comme renault et comme michelin qui
viennent devant vous refusez le procès
qu'on repousse des industries ça sauve
qui peu avant la présidence et les
commentaires faciles c'est la réalité
c'est que nous serons dans l'industrie
nous accueillons maintenant pascal
programme des échos il nous rejoint port
et la première question de l'émission
bonjour épreuve de vérité
les crédits classiques et les échos sur
pascal braud soir bonsoir jean marie le
guen soit on est aujourd'hui à sept mois
de l'élection présidentielle
on sent bien que l'exécutif et et
tourner totalement ouvert cette échéance
électorale
le sentiment qu'on a que j'ai moi en
tout cas c'est que plus aucun dossier
d'importance ne sera lancée d'ici au
mois d'avril d'ici au mois de mai est ce
que je me trompe
attendez il ya deux trois secondes on
parlait de d'alstom ce n'est pas un
dossier un peu parlé donc le programme
législatif il ya malheureusement le
supérieur d'état chargé des relations
avec le parlement
je suis complètement bouquet comme on
dit et nous avons un travail un plan de
charge qui est très important bon encore
cet après midi une réforme extrêmement
importante va être mis sur pied qui est
celle de la réforme des masters je dis
ça mais ce que dit le mot le mot
sélection le mot sélection il peut
sortir de votre bouche quand même jean
marie le guen l'occurrence mais j'ai
aucun problème avec ça alors déploré
aucun nom et c'est une sélection avec
des droits c'est quelque chose qui est
intelligent c'est à dire que
effectivement il n'est pas dit ce qui
était le cas précédemment c'est que
n'importe qui est supposé faire
n'importe quel master quelles que soient
ses résultats quelle que soit sa
formation initiale mais a contrario il
est dit que toute personne qui veut
faire un master 2 en l'occurrence c'est
à dire la cinquième et la sixième année
pour de fac je dis ça pour tous ceux qui
sont pas les les adeptes des formations
universitaires bien pourra le faire en
lui proposant fera des propositions à
l'étudiant qui correspond réellement à
son niveau donc il y a plus qu'une
orientation non pas une sélection
couperet effectivement mais c'est une
réforme qui est très importante elle et
elle est fondamentale pour l'université
française je crois que un journal comme
le vôtre l'a souvent souligné
voilà vous voyez ça tombe aujourd'hui je
peux pas je pourrais encore égrainé
un seul objectif c'est de c'est d'avoir
un master réformes et à la rentrée 2010
est ce à dire qu'il faut aller vite quel
sera le vecteur de cette renault on
discute encore il ya plusieurs
possibilités
je pense que raï à une ppl sénatoriale
qui est
d'ailleurs porté par un sénateur
oui de la majorité sénatoriale donc de
l'opposition nationale qui devrait
permettre d'accrocher cette réforme
la ppl était beaucoup plus modeste mais
on a un temps parlementaire qui nous
permettra d'avancer c'est quand même
c'est très important
alors vraiment remercier votre question
sur les réformes j'en ai d'autres alors
il est un sujet qui est dans l'air du
temps qui monte qui ne fait pas encore
l'objet d'un rien d'un projet législatif
c'est le revenu universel
le premier ministre manuel valls en a
parlé le week-end dernier encore en
appelant
l'ouverture d'un débat sur le sujet ça
typiquement c'est une réforme d'ampleur
qu'on n'imagine pas lancée avant le
avant le printemps
c'est plus un thème de campagne oui
c'est une armée c'est même une réflexion
stratégique sur la société gea soyons
très très honnête ou bien sûr alors il y
à une première marche vous savez une
marche qui est fou fait en ce moment par
le gouvernement qui est de simplifier de
rassembler les différents minima sociaux
c'est une première étape de
simplification mais la question
fondamentale du revenu universel
c'est une réforme de société absolument
colossal qui ne se décide pas en
appuyant sur un bouton ni dans un projet
de loi de finances ni même soyons très
honnête par un engagement présidentiel
qui dirait ah ben non alors que on a et
compte d'abord il moi je pense qu'il
faut discuter de ce genre de choses je
pense que ce que fait le premier
ministre et qui pose sur la table une
question essentielle qui a à voir avec
la solidarité mais qui a à voir aussi
avec une réflexion beaucoup plus
fondamentale sur le travail à 5 ou à 10
ans nous avons connu la révolution
d'internet ces dernières années nous
connaîtrons une deuxième révolution
d'internet vous le savez le big data la
connectique la robotique et bien cela
nous amène à réfléchir à de nouveaux
outils à une nouvelle approche de
l'emploi et du travail
car vos sujets de campagne quelques sur
le sujet de projets de société
quelques mots sur l'assurance chômage on
sait que partenaires sociaux n'ont pas
réussi à se mettre d'accord au début de
l'été sur une nouvelle convention unedic
la balle est maintenant dans le camp du
gouvernement quels sont les scénarios
sur la table
le premier ministre a dit qu'on
réfléchissait à plusieurs pistes mais
d'abord il faut il faudrait vérifier que
les partenaires sociaux certes ils ont
échoué vous avez raison avant l'été mais
qui ne sont pas à même et qu'il souhaite
même se débarrasser du problème ou lieu
où + lecteur ne pas le prêter pour être
plus objectif
bon s'il était vérifier qu'ils ne sont
pas en état de traiter le problème
effectivement je vais ça fait partie des
questions sous jacentes du fait que le
gouvernement a décidé des choses tout à
fait stratégique encore
et il réformer jusqu'au bout il faudra
effectivement réformer l'assurance
chômage parmi les pistes y en a
plusieurs qui sont sur la table
vous les connaissez elles sont pas
arbitrées si j'en cite une on va dire
tout de suite que c'est déjà arbitré ce
qui n'est pas le cas mais il ya eu
toujours favorable à une éventuelle
dégressivité des allocations chômage
vous on n'aurait rien dit ici oui mais
parce que j'étais gêné oui dans
certaines conditions ne soyons pas trop
simpliste et veulent par exemple je
pense qu'il faudrait distinguer les gens
qui ont une carrière longue et à
l'intérieur d'une entreprise et les gens
qui ont une carrière courte mais c'est
un avis personnel qui fera partie de la
discussion évidemment il ya aussi je
m'étais aussi prononcé pour la taxation
des contrats courts bien je pense que
c'est moi je pense que c'est une idée
intéressante je sais que bon si elle
devait être plus ou moins compensée par
une certaine forme de baisse de la
taxation des contrats longs ça
aboutirait à sortes de choses mais ça
cela vous me faites parler en tant que
responsable politique je l'accueille
revient volontiers c'est pas le membre
du gouvernement qui parle en
l'occurrence temps merci pascal de la fp
arrive maintenant pour la seconde partie
de l'épreuve de vérité
l'épreuve de vérité avec l' effet
bon sur la marque bonsoir bonsoir
monsieur le ministre alors les mauvais
sondages s'accumulent pour le président
le chômage la situation économique ne
montrent pas de signes de redressement
c'est même plutôt l'inversé dernières
semaines et on voit qu emmanuel macron
apparaît désormais comme le mieux placé
en tout cas face au président de la
république est ce que françois hollande
va renoncer face à la candidature
possible probable des manuels macron
voilà vous déjà vous êtes dans
l'anticipation complète avec des si si
si si si beaucoup de si donc moi je
serais très si vous le permettez
beaucoup plus pragmatique je dis
simplement aujourd'hui que j'ai bien
noté que nous avions et que le présent
la république avait un rapport à
l'opinion qu'ils étaient aujourd'hui
difficile nous sommes engagés dans un
travail qui commence à mon avis à se
faire entendre
qui est ce que je pourrais appeler la
réhabilitation de ce que nous avons fait
moi je le dis aux gens de gauche les
yeux dans les yeux et très clairement
nous n'avons pas à baisser la tête
devant ce que nous avons réalisé ces
commence à parler des landes avant moi
d'abord il faut dire un socle parce que
on est dans le holland bashing on est
dans le socialo bashing depuis
maintenant des mois et des mois et c'est
et on n'y a d'autre part de
responsabilité à la fois parce qu'on n'a
pas été forcément des bons pédagogues et
deuxièmement parce qu'une partie de la
gauche passe son temps à nous casser du
sucre sur le dos mais la réalité c'est
que le seul pays développé où la lutte
contre la pauvreté a progressé ces cinq
dernières années c'est la france la
réalité on en parlait à l'instant c'est
que l'allemagne est le seul pays
développé où les couches moyennes se
sont à peu près maintenu un certain
niveau
c'est la france le chômage le seul pays
en europe nom ne vous dit pas n'importe
quoi seul pays en europe ya un pays qui
fait nettement mieux que nous c'est
l'allemagne pour des raisons de
politique industrielle dont on pourrait
tout à fait parler et qu'ils méritent
d'ailleurs qui nous interpellent et
c'est pour ça et c'est pour ça et c'est
pour ça que nous avons mis en place une
politique qui fait en sorte de limiter
les coûts salariaux et que nous avons un
coût du travail qui aujourd'hui est
inférieur à celui de l'allemagne c'est
pour ça que nous avons rétabli les
marges des entreprises qui avait été
beaucoup abîmé
à la suite de la crise de 2008 tout ça
nous le faisons avec un respect des
finances publiques et avec aussi un
respect du modèle social comme ça c'est
le temps du bilan et nous n'avons nous
avons bien l'intention de défendre ce
bilan réhabilite avec la réhabilitation
du bilan avec en prenant acte évidemment
de nos erreurs de nos insuffisances ceci
est très claire deuxièmement j'irai très
vite là dessus bien que ce soit aux
oreilles de tous les français parce que
on est aujourd'hui en pleine campagne
des primaires à droite et on voit bien
ce que propose la droite ce que nous
avons fait ce que nous proposons est
donc il y a aussi une comparaison et
ceux qui ont glosé vaurien invité il ya
six mois il ya un an il ya deux ans
m'auriez dit mais alors la droite et la
gauche c'est la même chose va au moins
maintenant vous avez pu me poser la
question d'ailleurs vous me la posent et
pas parce que quand il ya le programme
de la droite dès les voiles avirons
troisièmement il faudra un projet il
faudrait une incarnation le président la
république je vous réponds et de mon
point de vue le mieux placé pour à la
fois apporter ce que je viens de dire
est allé alors j'entends bien que
emmanuel macron par exemple aujourd'hui
parce que il y à un concours de
circonstances d'abord c'est une
personnalité de qualité ça a été un très
bon ministre
deuxièmement il semble vouloir
s'abstraire des commentaires acheter
pesanteurs qui est de gauche qui est de
droite il semble aussi être relativement
peu précis encore sur les engagements
qui sont les siens et ceux ci correspond
il reste 50 il dresse le diagnostic
enfin vous l'avez entendu rire écouter
chez moi ça m'intéresse de toute façon
je suis intéressé par par part justement
ce travail intellectuel j'espère qu'il
va être produit j'espère qu'il sera de
qualité et j'espère qu'il servira de
notre pays et la gauche
d'une façon générale mais vous parlez
comme de lui en disant c'est un concours
de circonstances qui se retrouve le
mieux placé il est aujourd'hui je pense
si vous voulez je ne pense pas que
je ne fais pas de procès d'intention je
constate que sur ce je constate qu'il
n'a pas produit pour l'instant les
éléments politiques qu'ils fassent qu'à
mon avis la démarche qui est la sienne
soit crédible et durable
voilà maintenant je peux ranger attend
d'être comme on démontre le contraire
idéologiquement vous êtes quand même
assez proche de lui vous pourriez le
soutenir à l'avenir mais moi j'ai
toujours soutenu j'étais un réformiste
je suis animateur du pôle réformiste je
l'avais invité une autre université
d'été à pessac léognan j'ai des nuances
jeu par exemple je suis pas socialisée
râle je suis quelqu'un qui est sur une
position effectivement pro entreprises
je crois mais je pense que l'état a un
rôle je pense que le régalien comme on
dit aujourd'hui un rôle et je ne suis
pas dans cette mission des nuances mais
et des nuances que que j'apprécie et et
donc il peut être tout à fait utile peut
être utile il peut être tout à fait
dommageable à la gauche il peut détruire
la gauche comme l'a dit manuel valls en
oui si si sa candidature s'avérait être
une candidature qui fait que la gauche
ne peut pas être la gauche de
responsabilité moi je pense qu'il faut
la clarification de ce point de vue je
suis d'accord avec lui faut une
clarification politique la gauche
aujourd'hui il ya une gauche dans le
monde entier qui est de la gauche de
l'indignation et qui refuse d'assumer
les responsabilités et ça donne
l'effondrement du parti travailliste en
grande-bretagne
ça donne le ps aux oeufs et et podemos
qui n'a d'autre objet que de faire que
monsieur rajoy soit à nouveau investie
en espagne ça donne la critique de
monsieur de sipera ce après que monsieur
tsipras s'est avancé on le critique et
on l'affaiblît dans la dure gestion qui
est la sienne en france
bref bref bref donc la france j'ai pas
besoin de rappeler ce que les épisodes
douloureux que nous avons connue depuis
des années avec ses soi-disant frondeur
et donc de cette gauche là qui ne veut
pas gouverner elle nous pose problème et
je pense que il faut une clarification
c'est à dire moi je suis français
je dis aux électeurs de gauche l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on voit bien les
enjeux ils sont fondamentaux n'oublions
pas l'extrême droite qui est à 30% et
qui sera vraisemblablement un adversaire
qui n'est pas battu d'avancé au second
tour de l'élection présidentielle étude
avance elle n'est pas battu d'avancé ce
qu'ils pensent ce qu'ils pensent jeu
soyons très précis que il n'y a aucune
chance et qu'il n'y a aucun danger du
côté de l'extrême droite se trompe
lourdement
et je vais perdre contre marine le pen à
gauche la droite peuvent perdre contre
eux 20 c'est pour ça que moi j'appelle
au dépassement de la gauche et j'appelle
à une recomposition politique qui fasse
que nous rassemblions les républicains
parce que je crois que s'il n'y a pas un
rassemblement des républicains alors
effectivement une droite sectaire une
gauche sectaire peuvent perdre face aux
marines loiret vous vous disiez
justement que la candidature d'emmanuel
mâcon pouvait détruire la gauche dans le
sens où elle la priverait peut-être d'un
axe d'un aîné ses rares chances d'accès
au second tour mais mme emmanuel macron
pourrez vous inversez la réflexion il
pourrait dire bah finalement françois
hollande va m'empêcher possiblement
d'avoir des chances d'être au second
tour et c'est moi le mieux placé des
deux donc c'est à lui de sortir oui mais
d'abord je veux d'abord on peut toujours
spéculer comme ça mais d'abord je pense
que pour l'instant il ne s'est pas
rattachée à la gauche je ne dis pas que
lui même n'est pas de gauche
de passage jeudi par jeudi pour
l'instant sa démarche il ne l'a pas
placé dans un renouvellement de la
gauche c'est une déjà une nuance que
j'ai avec lui moi je suis pas pour
l'immobilisme
je pense que l'immobilisme conduit la
gauche dans le mur mais je pense que ce
renouveau il s'adresse à la gauche qu'il
faut prendre la gauche qu'il faut
prendre le corps de la gauche et le
maître et le mettre à la hauteur des
événements et des responsabilités qui
sont les nôtres
je ne suis pas pour partir de la gauche
je ne suis pas pour déserter le terrain
de la gauche c'est ce qu'il fait lui je
pense que pour l'instant il ne s'est pas
positionné comme un danger j'attends
j'attends qu'il se positionne mais a par
ailleurs il attire un certain nombre de
2,2 dessous est d'inspiration de soutien
et ses soutiens peuvent parfois manche
manquée à la gauche réformiste que
je souhaite mettre en avant et donc il y
a il ya effectivement un danger la
stratégie qui est qui est la sienne
n'est pas neutre c'est pas une stratégie
sans conséquence en 8c un danger vous
l'avais dit il ya donc j'essayais de
dire 17 ans et dont la conclusion
c'était cela merci marc c'est terminé
pour vous le souhaitez
mais pour l'instant c'est michael aimait
ce qui vient pour la troisième partie de
l'épreuve de vérité
michel roussin jean marie le guen alors
dire qu'avec la droite serait pire
peut-il suffire
en fait vous nous refaites l'histoire de
quelque chose qu'on le connaît bien
regarder c'est en 86 regarder cette
affiche de campagne
attention la droite revient et c'est le
remake de ce qu'on a connu en 86 matchs
croyez que vous alliez la montre et
c'est pour ça voilà bon excusez moi
non parce qu'elle était très rare était
rigolote accuse alors non non c'est on
n'est plus du tout dans la même
situation
d'abord parce que c'est pas moi ce que
je dis simplement j'ai parlé du bilan
jeudi comparer vous savez c'est leclerc
les prix vous prenez votre machin vous
comparez voilà vous avez le comparateur
de prix tous les gens d'accord
aujourd'hui ont l'habitude de comparer
je leur demande qu'une seule chose moi
je leur dis pas attention je leur dis
attention regardez bien ce qui est écrit
regardez bien ce qu'ils disent et faites
votre choix
voilà donc je ne dis pas olala j'ai peur
jeudi les français doivent savoir très
clairement ce qu'ils vont peut-être ou
pas décidé en mai prochain ce jeudi que
dans le débat démocratique
la gauche et la droite ça veut dire
quelque chose alors qu'eux mêmes
je demande un dépassement de cet as de
cette opposition venir sur ce départ à
la baisse des prestations sociales
assumées par nicolas sarkozy en retraite
à 65 ans réforme du code du travail et
bien d'autres choses
assumez là aussi par alain juppé la
france est au courant et sap
ce qui va se passer si jamais la droite
devait revenir au pouvoir je pense que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya d'ailleurs
un petit peu dans notre débat nous tous
il ya un petit peu de
les françaises ont un grand scepticisme
et ils le doivent aux politiques et ils
ont ils compris le scepticisme des
promesses c'est à dire que pour beaucoup
d'entre eux je le crois aujourd'hui 1
ils n'ont pas complètement lui comme
vous et moi
les programmes on va pas leur en vouloir
c'est parfois un peu austère
deuxièmement je pense qu'il ya une sorte
de scepticisme de rom finalement ils
disent ça mais ils ne le feront pas bien
je pense que c'est peut- il faut un
certain temps cela va percolé voilà
comme on dit
donc ça va perco l'état dira c'est à
dire je pense qu'il va il ya il va y
avoir un sens de conscience que ce que
propose à droite est ce que propose la
gauche où ce que fait la gauche ça n'a
rien à voir
c'est des choses enfin c'est des choses
très différentes que le programme qui
est celui de la droite aujourd'hui est
un programme qui n'est pas simplement
une alternance comme on a pu connaître
mais qui est véritablement un jeu direct
c'est un véritable je trouve je cherche
le mot mais véritablement une
déconstruction j'essaie de trouver un
mot qui ne soit pas trop facile et trop
brutale c'est une déconstruction
profonde on vous écoute vous niveau
ouvrir les portes de l'enfer c'est ce
que vous nous dites non écoutez moi je
moi je peux prendre toutes les mesures
ou plutôt que de rester dans le flou
alors je prends voilà lisf non l'impôt
sur les successions
monsieur sarkozy propose cinq cent mille
euros par français part par enfant ne
faisait pas bon ça correspond je vous le
rappelle ils avaient propos nous avons
mis nous cent mille euros 95 % des
français ne sont plus concernés par
l'impôt sur les successions
ce dont parle monsieur sarkozy s'est
donc les 5 % des français les plus
riches
voilà ça coûte 5 milliards d'euros 5
milliards d'euros c'est-à-dire un point
de tva s'est opérée somme il y arrivait
5 ça c'est une mesure est une mesure non
non non ils ont besoin d'autres mesures
on peut courir mais aussi que ces cinq
milliards d'euros à cinq pour cent des
français bien deuxièmement lisf l'impôt
sur le revenu je veux venir après l isf
l'impôt sur le revenu on dit 10 % 10 %
est de 40 milliards c'est une un
résultat non non pas c'est l'ensemble
qui fait 40 et bien sûr le sur l'impôt
sur le revenu c'est 7 milliards sur ces
7 milliards il ya 5 milliards à 10 % des
français les plus riches 10 % donc c'est
la politique des plus riches est ce que
vous êtes entré mais je les dis dès que
monsieur sarkozy a sorti son livre génie
c'est pas tout pour la france c'est tout
pour les régions vous savez moi je mets
les autres sa ligne les autres séries
nicolas sarkozy met un peu de choses
près au plan programmatique et au plan
fiscal et social
c'est un peu de choses près donc je
prends les choses moi vous savez on va
jouer le check up on prend les choses en
main qui parle oui exactement
on n'arrête pas de dire comme ça ils
sont droits qui sont de gauche etc
non 5 milliards d'euros 5 % les plus
riches recettes milliards d'euros 10%
les berguois là ils vont vous répondre
que de toute façon votre politique fait
que les riches ils sont déjà plus en
france alors mais parlons du ca monsieur
grossiord mais c'est c'est d'ailleurs
c'est pas moi qui vais dire ce que je
vous dis c'est thierry breton qui était
ministre
pendant cinq ans des finances de jacques
chirac et de jean pierre raffarin qu'est
ce qui dit il dit ce que propose la
droite aujourd'hui en l'occurrence
monsieur sarkozy il était plus précis
c'est exactement ce qu'il a proposé en
2007 avec le projet est pas laissez-moi
terminer sur ce sujet a dit le projet
t'es pas c'était le bouclier fiscal ça
consistait à donner aux en raison de ce
que vous dites de l'argent aux plus
riches moins nettement que ce qui est
proposé cette fois ci il faut dire que
comme il a besoin de se rattraper cette
fois ci il fait des chèques beaucoup
plus lourd bien mais cela aboutit à un
an un augmentation avant la crise de
2008 avant la crise de 2008 à une
rupture des engagements de la france
vis-à-vis de l'europe à une augmentation
considérable de la dette avant la crise
de 2008 qui a amené nos finances
publiques dans la situation où nous
sommes aujourd'hui est celle que l'on a
connue c'est à dire une augmentation une
augmentation de la dette publique
française de 500 milliards entre 2007 et
2012 et ceux ci étaient avant la crise
est ce que je dis là c'est thierry
breton qui le dit comprendre gros y est
fâché non non je ne suis pas du tout
fâché
j'essaye d'être précis parce que si on
résume votre propre arles
j'allais dire on va on sent voyez les
images comme celles-là la droite revient
à la bière au salon
bien compris c'était très drôle de
servir encore d'air non je pense que
justement c'est un petit peu oui mais on
n'est plus dans l'idéologie
comment expliquez vous que dans votre
camp à gauche alain juppé plaisent
autant ménages auront rien quand même
non mais les voter à la primaire pour
voter alain juppé oui oui mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya des électeurs de droite
qui vont aussi et attendait parfois des
électeurs qui ont voté françois hollande
ça a été une grande erreur de la gauche
peut considérer que les élections de
2012 c'est une victoire de la gauche
c'était une victoire de l'antisarkozysme
voilà ce qui est d'ailleurs peut-être un
peu court la jupe et ça serait une
victoire de l'antisarkozysme aussi j'en
sais rien ça il faudra voir ce que ça va
donner je n'en sais rien je dis
simplement que en 2012 beaucoup de mes
amis ont fait l'analyse selon laquelle
la gauche avait gagné les élections
présidentielles la réalité je le crois
c'était que nous avions gagné par
antisarkozysme ce qui est premièrement
c'était donc une erreur d'alice
deuxièmement l'anti sarkozysme c'est un
peu court
voilà donc en termes de pensée politique
ça me paraît un peu court bien donc
je rappelle ça donc je lentilles gauche
me paraît aussi aujourd'hui un peu court
bond après que donc des électeurs qui
ont été déçus en nage pas le nier
veulent participer à la primaire de la
droite
voilà je le constate moi il ne faudrait
soyons très clairs
non je suis inquiet je pense que les
gens je ne comprendrais pas mais je
n'imagine pas les gens qui se disent de
gauche
il n'est pas l'ensemble des gens qui ont
voté pour nous je viens de le répéter il
y avait des gens et je souhaite
d'ailleurs que j'en ai beaucoup ils
soient pas de gauche qui votent pour
nous moi je souhaite que les français
votent pour nous y a pas besoin d'un
passeport biologique pour voter pour
nous bon donc je dis simplement qu'il ya
des gens qui aient voté à un moment à
gauche qui aujourd'hui veulent aller je
ne comprends que des gens qui se disent
de gauche et qui s'assume comme telle
ait signé un truc comme quoi ils sont de
droite et du centre je ne comprends pas
très bien merci merci merci monsieur le
ministre la semaine prochaine
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui sera notre
invité à manger on l'interrogera sur la
théorie du chaos un voile à lui prêter
voilà merci à tous bon soir a très vite